[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et en attend
vos points de vue et en particulier vos
réponses à la question
donald trump doit-il se retirer de la
vie politique américaine près de cent
mille votants déjà la question est en
ligne depuis ce matin on l'a posera
ensuite à lucile schmid bonjour lucie la
cofondatrice notamment entre autres de
la fabrique écologique avec beaucoup
d'oeuvres beaucoup de talent c'est
normal et
c'est pas des moindres vous êtes là ce
soir ça vous vincent trémolet de villers
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
figaro bonsoir vincent et coordinateur
récemment de l'éloge de la politique de
platon à soljenitsyne c'est passionnant
et c'est chez tallandier dans
l'actualité aussi ce soir et il ya la
prise de parole de jean castex
qu'attendez-vous des annonces du premier
ministre il y en at il quelque chose à
attendre d'ailleurs en tout cas ce sera
à suivre en direct sur le site du figaro
et sur la page youtube figaro live comme
ce live d'ailleurs c'est l'info du jour
donald trump reconnaît donc la fin de
son mandat il y aura promet l'actuel
locataire de la maison blanche une
transition ordonnée
l'autre info c'est que la victoire de
joe biden a été bel et bien certifié en
tout début de matinée notamment par l'un
des rares journalistes français à se
trouver dans le capitole aux côtés des
impétrants notre confrère vincent joly
alors que s'est-il passé à ce moment on
je vous propose d'écouter d'abord la
lecture des événements par les api zar
ex-conseillère de l'ancien président
démocrate bill clinton qui comme vincent
très volé ces dernières heures se
trouvait sur lci amérique est évidemment
en état de choc c'est du jamais vu
on a carrément assister à une tentative
de coup d'état par un président qui a
des réflexes de dictateur d'opérette et
qui ne veut pas quitter le pouvoir qui
comprend que son moment s'achève qui
aurait pu sortir par la grande porte
il aurait pu peut-être trouvé un tout
petit goût de dignité mais il n'y est
pas parvenu
alors c'est un président en question a
enregistré une vidéo
elle a été supprimée depuis par twitter
mais on l'a récupéré notamment c'est un
document parce que pour l'heure c'est sa
dernière apparition télévisée
jolie ont du coup
pis
alors nous on doit retrouver la paix on
doit retrouver la loi et l'ordre dit
donald trump c'était parce qu'on avait
vu avant alors était ce un coup de chaud
qu'il laisse entendre ou bien un coup
d'état comme le dit les apps izard avant
d'en débattre je vous propose de
découper le témoignage de vincent joly
donc lui-même
juste avant son agression donc par un
nervi pro trump juste avant donc ils se
fassent bluesy et son téléphone avec
nous et avec lequel nous étions en train
de le joindre par skype
je ne pense pas et je ne crois vraiment
pas en tout cas c'est mon intime
conviction
je ne sens pas que les ses supporters
étaient venus là pour ça je pense
réellement un effet d'opportunité où il
ya eu un effet boule de neige il ya eu
le discours du président trump qui est
leur champion et le président trump a
encore une fois refusé d'admettre la
défaite a refusé de dire qu'il partirait
les supporters l'ont je pense a pris au
mot l'uci avant de donner la parole je
voudrais vous lire juste ce tweet qui
n'est pas le tweet d'un extrémiste
protruck loin s'en faut mais qui est
l'historien nicolas offenstadt qui dit
sans minimiser surtout à chaud il faut
veiller au sens des mots un coup d'état
ou un putsch supporte suppose la mise en
place même précaire d'un pouvoir de
remplacement illégal en un surgissement
la différence d'une émeute qui peut
aussi occuper des symboles du pouvoir
pour aller dans le sens de nicolas
offenstadt ce qui est vrai c'est que en
tous les cas après même si on a vu
notamment vincent se faire agresser en
direct ce qui nous a obligés de couper
le live à ce moment là on n'a pas vu un
pouvoir illégal ou même l'armée prendre
le pouvoir n'a pas vu comme en 1981 en
espagne un colonel avec un pistolet dans
le rôle dans le parlement comme ça avait
été le cas à cette époque
quel est votre sentiment sur ça c'est un
sentiment
assez partagés et il me semble que cette
expression de coup d'état alors on a
aussi parlé de tentative de coup d'état
parce que s'il y avait eu coup d'état en
tout cas ils auraient avorté puisque joe
biden venait de le dire a été confirmée
toute la question c'est au fond le
comportement de donald trump
depuis qu'il a été élu qui est à la fois
était le sommet des institutions et se
comportaient comme s'ils daignait aux
institutions leur fonctionnement
habituel et donc d'une certaine manière
et je dis pas ça pour jouer pour sur les
mots je me demande si donald trump n'a
pas été une forme de coup d'état
permanent depuis depuis son élection
depuis les quatre ans avec le sentiment
que on avait donc à la tête de l'état je
vous rappelle quelqu'un qui présidait
par tweet plutôt que de discuter ou de
négocier avec ses adversaires politiques
plutôt que de s'adresser à son parti est
aujourd'hui ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il ya eu un sentiment de mollesse en
fait d' absence de réactivité par
rapport à cette manière de trump de
présider le sentiment d'un coup de force
permanent de donald trump et que à
partir du moment je rappelle qu'il ya
quand même deux mois que les élections
aux tuyaux aux états unis et que depuis
deux mois donald trump martèle qu'il a
gagné l'élection alors même que à chaque
fois les institutions judiciaires les
institutions à washington lui dise qu'il
les a perdus donc il ya quelque chose en
tout cas d'une espèce de constitution de
fait que news de donner une réalité à
défectueuse qui est certainement en tout
cas je trouve une forme de coup d'état
par rapport à la manière dont on perçoit
la légitimité institutionnelle après la
le malaise que je ressens par rapport à
ce que vous dites c'est qu'en général
les coups d'état c'est pas ça
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
s'organise ya un complot tandis que là
il ya un homme seul qui utilisent la
virtualité et qui a trahi la virtualité
construit d'une certaine manière un
théâtre d'ombrés qui est qu'il a gagné
l'élection
il ya des personnes qui sont prêtes à le
suivre donc comment est ce qu'on fait
par rapport à nos catégories habituelles
sémantique philosophique politique pour
réagir par rapport à quelque chose qu'on
n'a jamais vus et on l'a jamais vu
notamment parce que pour nous les etats
unis c'est la première la plus grande
démocratie au monde et que donc imaginer
j'aurais aussi dire ça imaginez un coup
d'état aux états unis pour nous c'est
plus compliqué de l'imaginer
et en afrique en amérique latine et que
peut-être notre capacité à nous dire ça
ne peut pas arriver nous empêche de voir
la réalité de ce qui s'est passé
notamment du comportement de donald 3
vincent une réaction à ce que ce que dit
lucile façon plus générale que le regard
vous l'éditorialiste de politique
française que vous êtes directeur d'un
d'un ouvrage justement sur l'éloge de la
politique porte sur ces événements il me
semble que vous c'est pas un coup d'état
parce que comme le dit offenstadt y a
pas d'organisation il ya peut-être même
pas une volonté chez trump il laisse
faire ils goûtent à ce moment mais y'a
via pas il n'y a pas quelque chose
d'intentionnel ou ou de se structurer en
revanche ça m'apparaît comme une
cristallisation cet événement une
cristallisation qui témoignent qu'ils
eussent qui manifeste la profonde crise
démocratique dans laquelle les états
unis sont plongés depuis des années et
dans trump a été l'accélérateur mais
aussi le symptôme cirque eutrope n'est
pas né de rien trump est née d'une crise
démocratique et il est né de quoi il est
né d'une tension entre les institutions
ce qu'on appelle pas de l'état de droit
et les catégories populaires et les
catégories populaires l'ont porté au
pouvoir pour dire nous sommes aussi
légitime que les institutions et
l'immense erreur de trump c'est vraiment
la plus grande faute politique qui les
fait c'est qu'après sa victoire il
aurait dû passer ces quatre ans à
vouloir réconcilier l'état de droit et
ceux qui l'ont élu
en dix ans les deux ne sont pas
incompatibles c'est le principe de la
démocratie libérale au fait et lui a
continué de jouer sur une campagne
électorale permanente
ses adversaires sont rentrés tomber dans
le panneau aussi en étant univoque
caricaturaux et en systèmes avec lui si
bien qu'on avait selon la formule
d'alain finkielkraut une bêtise
sophistiqué face à une bêtise bête
c'était ça le combat de trump et des
antilles trump heist et et à partir de
là il n'y a plus de politique possible
il n'y a plus de conversation si vite
possible il ya plus de controverses
possible a plus de débat possible et là
il ya même plus de reconnaissance de
légitimité équivalente à entre les deux
camps c'est à dire que le principe même
qui doit faire leur unité on leur
demande pas de s'aimer on leur demande
d'accepter qu'une élection
a eu lieu et que quelqu'un l'a gagné ça
y est les trump its maintenant ne le
crois pas sont installés dans une autre
légitimité
une autre réalité est ce la leçon pour
nous je pense c'est très très grave ce
qu'on a vu hier parce que ça nous
indique ce qui peut se passer dans
d'autres pays en occident c'est de
limiter la politique à un affrontement
binaire but i'll frontale entre une
force hostile et maléfique caricatural
comme trump est une force démocrate
gentil et bienveillante qui serait le
camp d'en face ça fini comme çà de
préfère une alternance qui est fondée
sur des vrais débats sur des vraies
controverse sur sur sur ce qui est
normalement le principe démocratique et
malheureusement on le voit en france
vous me parlez de la politique française
le système macron le pen est un système
d'affrontements où il ya l'alternance
est inimaginable puisque personne
n'imagine marine le pen
et ça ça finit mal donc le si on doit
tirer dans cette vente pour autant quand
vous dites ça fitness a cepandant show
couple parce que c'est intéressant coded
ça finit mal sa fille qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça finit mal
est ce que ça veut dire par exemple que
marine le pen pour ses adversaires
arrivent au pouvoir ou bien est ce que
ça veut dire que ça ternit dans la
violence dans le chaos ça veut dire que
entre les deux camps quand ce sont ces
deux camps la y en a nous y en a dans
d'autres pays il y à eux et nous il ya
le bien le mal il y a absolument je suis
la démocratie l'autre n'est pas la
démocratie
il ya la remise en cause de la
légitimité de celui qui est élu
et à partir de là il ya plus de
possibilités de travail en commun et et
donc il faut restaurer des possibilités
des propositions politiques qui ne sont
pas fondées simplement sur des
personnalités sur l'émotion sur sur la
compulsion parce que tweet c'était aussi
les tweeds trump lapsus c'était aussi ça
mais je pense que le danger devant
lequel on est c'est de dire bon on s'est
débarrassé de lui et d'oublier ce qu'il
ya derrière trump skis et dernier tome
c'est une réalité politique et sociale
qu'il faut pas qu'il ne faut pas oublier
donc
voilà moi je demande il me semble que
que cet événement devrait indiquer à
tous amoureux de la démocratie libérale
qu' il ya des causes qu'il y mène est
que tu il faut tout faire pour éviter
d'y arriver mais je crois qu'il ya aussi
par rapport à ce que vous dites vincent
vous dit
trump a commis une erreur il aurait dû
réconcilier en fait le peuple et les
institutions et les élites et moi je
crois que ce qui est très intéressant
avec trump c'est qu'on a découvert une
psychologie est un être qui de toute
façon ne souhaitait pas être constructif
c'est à dire qu on est face à quelqu'un
et on peut penser que bolton arrow on
peut penser quelque part qu erdogan
c'est tout ce qu'on appelle les
démocrates eurent aujourd'hui on peut
penser que leur sonar aux molson a
recruté entre hommes jusqu'au bout c'est
pas étonnant c'est à dire que hélas
c'est une manière d'exercer le pouvoir
qui aujourd'hui repose effectivement sur
le jeu vous l'avez dit des émotions mais
les émotions peuvent être positives
lacets sont les émotions destructrice et
moi je pense que là où on est gêné sur
l'expression de coup d'état c'est qu'on
pense qu'un coup d'état ça substitue un
pouvoir à un autre et non pas saborder
lisent ça mais le désordre a détruit
alors qu'on peut considérer que donald
trump avait un objectif c'était quelque
part de détruire la confiance dans les
institutions et ceux qui sont au pouvoir
dans les institutions auprès d'une large
partie de la société américaine et qu'en
ce sens il a réussi oui mais pardon du
cil deux jours cette objection bien ce
que socialiste quelque chose de très
anciens moi je me souviens par exemple
au moment de l'affrontement de bouche
gore en 2000 déjà on parlait de
l'atmosphère de l'atmosphère pourri à
washington donc déjà cette défiance à
l'égard des élites et même les
déchéances de certains médias avant
récurrence peut-être de médias étrangers
mais à l'égard de de l'ambiance
politique à washington est quand même
quelque chose mais les anciens c'est
très ancien mais en revanche le fait
qu'ils aient des morts et le fait ces
images qui sont deux a priori les morts
ce sont des manifestants selon lui le
programme
oui c'était des pros trompe mais
justement enfin que des américains qui
se disent des patriotes envahissent le
lieu où on est en train de certifier la
victoire du président élu ça dit quelque
chose en tout cas de terribles sur la
destruction des institutions de l'esprit
des uns
tu sion et ça c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que d'une certaine
manière c'est patriotes contre patriotes
on essaie ça et ça c'est ça cette année
les intérêts très préoccupant c'est à
dire que le regard porté sur l'intrusion
dans le dans le capitole est d'abord un
regard de sacrilège chance aux
négociations mais ceux qui le font dans
leur psychologie considère ce qu'il ce
qu'ils s'emparent d'un lieu qui est le
leur et qu'ils restaurent la légitimité
du lieu qu'ils étaient des voiliers pour
les gens qui l'ont corrompue donc quand
on arrive à ce niveau là il est ce sera
pour de nouvelles donnes un défi mais
extraordinairement difficile il est
quasiment impossible de 2,2 réconcilier
tout cela parce que le le principe de
réalité
l'expérience commune le regard commun
sur l'organisation sociale politique
n'est même plus partagés il y avait des
interviews on en a vu pas mal hier de
manifestants qui considérait que de leur
bon droit il faisait ce qu'ils avaient
fait est qu'ils n'étaient simplement lac
en train de mener une geste patriotique
et ça donc elle ressemble à une début de
ces sessions enfin c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça nous redonne la
parole tout de suite mais pour étayer ce
que vous dites non mais j'ai juste avant
le live que nous avons fait avec vincent
jeudi d'appeler leur mandeville pouvait
pas être la raison personnelle mais qui
va nous manquer explique et qui dit
c'est le symptôme d'une situation quand
même révolutionnaire
aux etats unis c'est c'est bon déploré
les images déplorables mais pas au sens
où l'entendait hillary clinton mais
c'était des images dans tous les cas qui
étaient l'illustration d'une situation
qui est très fort parce que et leur a
rappelé que également il ya toujours une
tension politique aux états unis et que
la dernière fois où donc c'est 1814 où
il ya une attaque du capitole mais en
1968 il y avait eu des émeutes très
forte où on a craint justement que des
émeutes raciales et qui est des maîtres
qui n'est plus tôt dès qu'ils venaient
de l'extrême gauche et on avait craint
justement une occupation du capitole à
ce moment là et que là on est con on a
vu quand même mois de juin tout cet été
avec la manifestation blake lively
matters des fonds de police qui a une
situation quand même qui est extrêmement
extrêmement extrêmement tendue
extrêmement révolutionnaire comme le dit
et redit leur nom mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que elle vous ramène à
l'histoire des etats-unis c'est-à-dire
qu'elle dit quelque part que l'histoire
de ce pays fait que l'insurrection la
sécession c'est quelque chose qui a une
réalité y compris aujourd'hui et on voit
comment l'histoire peut éclairer ce qui
vient de se passer
après ce qui est aussi au delà des états
unis qui nous intéresse nous français
c'est évidemment la question de la
légitimité des institutions comment est
ce qu'on fait pour avoir des
institutions qu'ils soient respectés
qu'ils soient respectables qui est une
légitimité vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de la
société alors qu'on a des sociétés de
plus en plus divisé on est renvoyé
sanaa s'est beaucoup moins grave mais on
est renvoyé à ce qu'on a ressenti par
rapport aux mouvements des gilets jaunes
on est renvoyé à la manière dont
peut-être aujourd'hui on conteste
emmanuel macron des qui bouge ainsi l'
on est renvoyé au sentiment que ceux qui
sont dans les institutions sont quelque
part dans une espèce dans un jeu de
massacre
et comment est ce qu'on va faire pour
avoir des institutions qui porte le
souffle démocratie libérale aux
institutions il
d'abord elles sont profondément en crise
il faut le reconnaître il ya un problème
très important de représentation elles
ne représentent plus la nation donc des
gens se sentent exclus et quand les gens
qu'on commence à considérer que le
levier démocratique
le vote n'est plus le houleux débats ne
sont plus des moyens de se faire
entendre ils arrivent à la violence
c'est ça c'est ça qu'il faut absolument
absolument éviter
et c'est un travail qui moi je suis très
préoccupé parce que je pense que tout
indique que l'on risque d'arriver à ces
extrémités là mais mais c'est un travail
qui no kill ou oui enfin qui ne concerne
pas simplement les institutions qui
concerne l'école la formation la culture
parce que dans la possibilité qu'elle
traîne installer une sur réalité dans
les esprits il a quand même profité
d'esprit qui n'était pas structuré qui
n'est pas de distance de culture qui
aurait pu voir qu'il disait n'importe
quoi donc il y à il ya ce problème via
lequel il ya quand même le problème du
système d'information continue
accompagné de la compulsion de réseaux
sociaux qui fait que les gens n'ont plus
qu'une distance donc le qu'une nuance
avec ceux employés vivent que les la
binah risation de tout débat fécond on
en a plus possible de possibilité
d'avoir une vision intermédiaire et que
tout ça construit et on le voit dans
notre société
aujourd'hui un climat qui fait que ce
qui devait être le débat est devenu un
combat ce qui devait être une
confrontation se présente comme un
affrontement et ce vent qui vient
décevant vient des états unis et ça doit
nous préoccuper et peut-être que ce mois
je porte à ce que lee l'orge très
attention aux images et quand j'ai vu
ces images d'hier
pour moi c'était les deux mots qui me
sont inscrits ces insurrections des
révolutions c'est à dire que c'est la
geste c'est la geste habituel
alors on dit bon finalement ça s'est
calmé mais bon il ya quand même un seuil
très très spectaculaire qui a été
franchi et donc il faut les prendre très
au sérieux
et puis il ya aussi cette question vous
dites parlait beaucoup de débats c'est
qu'est ce que je veux croire
et qu'est ce que je veux débattre c'est
à dire que là dedans il ya aussi l'idée
que quoi que tu débattent
quoique vous débattent y est on ne vous
croira pas et ça c'est je pense que
c'est un vrai élément sur la question
des faits cnri un sentiment de ne pas
être écouté d'être écoutés nous regarder
puis au fait c'est là c'est la
construction d'une vision du monde qui
n'est plus fondée sur un réel commun
mais sur des présupposés des
représentations qui sont contraires donc
à partir de là et ses représentations
elles sont entretenues et a participé
lequel voulait contredit la halle et
yahya yahya un post facebook qui vous
dit mais non vous n'avez pas compris et
donc vous l'algorithme vous enferme en
fait dans votre dans vos représentations
et vous empêchent d'atteindre la
contradiction qui vous permettrait de
mieux comprendre
donc c'est un défi considérable alors
justement c'est le dernier point il moi
un peu moins d'une dizaine de minutes il
faudrait qu'on parle d'eux donc 2
du confinement éventuelle mais livré
jeudi a posé son confinement
j'aimerais voulu faire l'impasse enfin
bon certaines d'actualité je lis et
c'est le réel et on respecte leur et
plus il est gentil et donc voilà donc je
dois en fait on va en parler vous n'avez
pas eu à fait prêt à y échapper
juste une chose sûre puisque vous parlez
de facebook des réseaux sociaux
le phénomène car ceux d'hier soir qui a
uriné dit c'était quand même que le
président s'était voit son compte
retirer sur sur twitter bon aude
lancelin qui ne figure donc de la gauche
médiatique en france et nous dit des dix
faces buzz facebook facebook par dans
béni banni la vidéo de tram qui appelait
pourtant ses partisans à se retirer et
il faudra tout de même s'interroger à
froid sur ses interventions désormais
courant des gaffes à qui ce passe de
plus en plus clairement au dessus des
états est ce que ça aussi c'est pas un
syndrome un symptôme préoccupant c'est
peut-être un symptôme préoccupant mais
c'est en tout cas un indice du fait que
le flux l'immédiateté
le fait qu'il n'y a pas de conclusion
c'est quelque chose qui me pose une
question à nos démocraties libérales
comme vous le dites et donc tout l'enjeu
c'est comment est-ce qu'on organise
cette espèce de contrat social qui
inclura la réalité de la vie politique
telle qu'elle se joue aujourd'hui alors
que nos institutions sont déphasés est
dépassé moi je ne sais pas si je pense
comme aude lancelin c'est à dire que
j'ai regardé cette vidéo que vous avez
récupéré miraculeusement car vous êtes
très bon et si sur les réseaux sociaux
et donc ça commence quand même par
donald trump dix ans nous avons remporté
une éclatante victoire
donc je comprends aussi qu'on puisse
retirer cette vidéo parce que je trouve
qu'il ya un déni de réalité qui ça
commence par ça donc moi je ne sais pas
si je pense comme aude lancelin mais en
tout cas je crois que le fait que
facebook twitter soit beaucoup plus
actif aujourd'hui est qu'il est censuré
le l'ancien président
américain depuis deux mois quand on est
artiste le mot de censure oui les belles
censuré comment dirais-je pour empêcher
la diffusion en effet que news j'ai
trouvé qu'il peut être que j'ai pas le
bon mot maintenant j'ai trouvé que
c'était bien en fait qu' il accepte de
s'impliquer parce que d'une certaine
manière personne ne pouvait le faire à
leur place je ne dis pas que c'est
quelque chose qui doit structurellement
être maintenu mais en situation
d'urgence
j'ai trouvé que c'était bien moi alors
je suis comme vous je pense est
parfaitement cynique ce qu'ils ont fait
ah oui c'est à dire qu'ils vivent
c'est quand même des réseaux qui vivent
de ces excès de ces provocations de ce
compte twitter qui a des millions
millions 2,2 d'abonnés je pense que
donald trump a rendu à truites heures un
service it énormissime durant son mandat
puisqu'il a gouverné par insulteur et
que ça ne les a pas gêné à ce moment là
donc il ya quelque chose dans leur
décision qui bon sur le plan des
libertés publiques me gêne c'est sur le
plan de la morale me paraît un peu
hypocrite mais après après simplement je
termine puis je ne vais pas je ne vais
pas
plaindre donald trump à ce qu'il est il
et il est puni par là où il a péché il a
choisi il a choisi cet outil pour
contourner les outils traditionnels que
lui donnait la politique américaine
il les a choisis les à utiliser ces
outils se retourne contre lui il devait
s'y attendre et il n'a jamais accepté de
d'avoir la dignité la tenue à solennité
la distance d'un chef d'état qui n'a pas
besoin d'eux on pourrait très bien avoir
un chef d'état qui ne twitte pas et ils
sont le pays s'en porterait voilà donc
je vais pas le plein mais je vais pas
féliciter la seule ceux qui ont pris
cette décision je suis pas en train de
dire que twitter et facebook ont fait sa
part idéaliste oui je pense qu'ils l'ont
fait sous pression et je pense que
c'était intéressant par ailleurs ce
qu'ont fait les journalistes américains
on censure en enrayant plan ce terme
le président américain lorsqu'il
répondait l'effet d'une hausse est aussi
quelque chose qui doit vous interrogez
vous qui êtes journaliste sur votre
métier
est ce que c'est quelque chose si on
était confronté à cette situation il
faut avoir l'audace de le faire mais
vous croyez pas qu'on l'ait c est ce qu
on a été très intéressant pour moi
c'était un événement très important
quand les télés américaines ont arrêté
l'audition de donald trump
parce que moi il me semble que ça
alimente la sueur réalité dans laquelle
vivent les trump heist
donc c'est à dire que vous voyez il à
télé le blog ça veut bien dire qu'il a
raison et c'est il me semble que c'est
plus
ambitieux de le laisser finir et de
faire venir trois intervenants pour dire
là il a dit n'importe quoi là il a dit
n'importe quoi là il a dit n'importe
quoi s'est pas fait c'est une discussion
intéressante à voir et qu'il faudrait
avoir des cas pratiques
je vous propose qu'on est dans un autre
débat non mais c'est intéressant c'est
vraiment on est au coeur d'un débat et
justement je crois qu'on a pu en tous
les cas être fidèle à vos inspirations
lassant pour en abordant quand même les
choses sensibles en essayant de prendre
le temps d'aller un peu au fond des
choses même si c'est toujours cours
parce que c'est un temps médiatique
je vous donne la parole justement parce
que c'est quand même la logique
également sur les réseaux trump n'a
jamais été un homme politique
le dit nadia sur youtube il ne le sera
jamais ce serait souhaitable qu'à
l'avenir ils s'abstiennent de maintenir
l'illusion et nadia répond justement la
question qui est posée sur le site du
figaro
donald trump doit-il quitter la vie
politique américaine
et pour l'instant c'est un oui le qui
l'emportent 77% au dernier pointage
nous n'avons pas à juger des choix
politiques des américains qu'il soit
électeur ou non nous dit daniel et je ne
suis pas super fan de trump nous dit
nicole mais vu ce qu'il a subi depuis
quatre ans de la part des démocrates
on peut comprendre son amertume et marie
amélie putallaz qui assure l'animation
du chat dit que les internautes
débattent également de savoir qui sont
les envahisseurs du capitole du membre
du parc du tea party certains prétendent
même des antilles fin ça on n'en a pas
vu beaucoup comme hier en tous les cas
dans les images qu'on avait la liberté
de ce con de dire ce qu'on pense même si
je n'accepte pas les propos de nesle
trump cela reste un président des états
unis si on sent sur un président
français
comment allons-nous réagir demande
michel sur youtube je vous propose qu'on
ait ce débat une une autre fois mais il
est passionnant et on n'y coupera pas
alors on coupera pas non plus à la
question faut-il un nouveau confinement
vous allez pouvoir suivre dans quelques
minutes
l'allocution de jean castex le débat qui
revient donc c'est faut-il ou non
reconfirmer avant d'avoir vos points de
vue et bien je vous propose d'écouter
là aussi on l'a déjà eu on n'y coupe pas
celui de deux médecins axel kahn eric
comme à la fin du mois on est dans une
situation très difficile avant la fin du
mois la fin du mois 102 j'espère me
tromper on est confiné les écoles sont
fermées et céda confinement extrêmement
dur comme le premier confinement pour
l'instant je pense que c'est trop tôt
pour recommander un confinement général
en tout cas général vedette à un recond
finement local sera envisagée dans
certains endroits ça je ne sais pas mais
il n'est pas inenvisageable qui
faillirent confiné art
il ya une question qui est sous jacente
qui monte et qui est d'ailleurs
largement abordée dans les ces dernières
heures sur le site du figaro et dans
l'édition papier du figaro aujourd'hui
c'est cette notion de territorialisation
d'avoir un confinement différencier les
élus locaux
les élus du territoire président région
prétendent qu'ils peuvent faire et
qu'ils peuvent me faire est-ce que ce
qu'il faut les croire
ils ont montré que pour beaucoup de
choses en tout cas logistique c'est est
capable de faire et de mieux faire que
l'état central après le les restrictions
territoriales elles finissent toujours
par remplir l'intégralité de la carte de
france
on l'a vu avec le port du masque on l'a
vu avec la fermeture des bars on l'a vu
et donc si deux ou trois régions
décident de confiner
[Musique]
l'eau région très vite toute la france
peut-être pas la bretagne qui pour le
moment a vraiment des chiffres très très
inférieur au reste risque de confiner la
question moi je crains qu'on n'échappe
pas à ce nouveau confinement
la question c'est lequel c'est à dire
est ce que c'est ce 8 novembre
parce que c'est celui de mars c'est une
novembre était quand même supportable
parce que les enfants allaient à l'école
et qu'il était plus souple que dans son
application
celui de mars et peut-être légitime sur
le plan sanitaire
mais il me paraît extraordinairement
périlleux sur le plan économique et
psychologique parce qu'on n'est pas à
celui de mars était printemps on a eu un
très beau printemps là on est au début
du mois de janvier
imaginer un scénario à l'anglais c'est à
dire six semaines avec tout le monde
chez soi
plus d'école plus de commerces mon
essentiel le télétravail imposé
c'est une décision très lourde à prendre
parce qu'elle peut avoir des
conséquences économiques évidemment mais
à mon avis très très sensibles sur des
psychologies épuisés et las et de toute
cette histoire sur la territorialisation
ce que disait vincent s'était
apparemment une démonstration quand même
d'une plus grande efficience une plus
grande efficacité votre point de vue sur
ça mais moi je pense que le sujet c'est
que c'est un sujet national et qu'il
faut évidemment que l'état concerte avec
les acteurs territoriaux c'est à dire
que ça doit être quelque chose où il ya
une délégation dans la mise en oeuvre et
au fond toute la difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est que on voit bien qu on a une mise
en oeuvre qui reste très centralisé
s'est compliquée par l'arrivée du vaccin
qui en même temps est un facteur
d'espoir est essentielle
bonjour j'entends bien axel kahn qui dit
qu'il va falloir nous reconfirmons comme
en mars
enfin il ya quand même le vaccin donc
moi je pense qu'il faut pas oublier ça
alors certes la stratégie vaccinale
patine un peu pour l'instant mais de
toute façon ça va aller on dynamique et
c'est clair que du coup les personnes à
risque seront vaccinés les soignants
seront vaccinés donc moi en tout cas je
ne fera pas en un confinement type mars
en revanche je pense que si on arrive à
refaire la confiance entre l'état et les
acteurs territoriaux ça serait quand
même très bien pour le gouvernement
parce qu'on voit bien que jean castex
qui subit aujourd'hui énormément de
critiques
emmanuel macron est un peu plus en
retrait mais même olivier ferrand qui
était pourtant l'icône est en train
d'être attaquée c'est lié au fait qu'il
n'arrive pas suffisamment a délégué la
mise en oeuvre est donc pour eux ce
serait bien et puis ce serait bien d'une
certaine manière pour nous démontrer que
l'action publique peut être mené sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire
alors ça pose aussi juste une petite
pause aussi
des questions sur les inégalités entre
régions c'est à dire que les régions
sont inégalement peuple et enée galement
doté en infrastructures sanitaires et
inégalement dotées en médecins
c'est à dire qu'il ya aussi des déserts
médicaux en france donc comment est ce
qu'on fait moi je crois pas plutôt là je
crois pas du tout que la
territorialisation se suffisent à
elles-mêmes
en revanche il ya des mères qui
demandent à être associés je pose
d'ailleurs la question du bon niveau des
bonnes personnes avec lesquelles
s'associent et c'est à dire que s'il ya
des gens qui sont volontaires moi je
crois qu'il devrait presque y avoir une
espèce de mise en oeuvre nationale mais
avec ça a été fait d'ailleurs sur la
liste l'histoire la vaccination accéléré
il faut utiliser toutes les bonnes
volontés
lorsqu'il ya dynamique territoriale qui
apparaît pour le moment c'est pas du
tout le cas si vous vous donnez des cas
concrets
valérie pécresse depuis le mois de
novembre propose une carte avec les
écoles d'infirmières et les écoles les
plus près et de deux des hôpitaux pour
pouvoir mener l a pas de réponse à la rs
lui dit je ne sais pas quoi vous dire
le maire de cana de frigidaire à moins
90 degrés à le palais des festivals qui
est prêt et il va demander à la grèce ce
qui peut faire leurs études iqee n'en
sais rien le couple préfet maire qui a
été tellement vantées n'existe pas et
parfois le préfet découvre les décrets
qu'il doit appliquer à la télévision
donc il ya quand même ça il ya des cds
chose que j'ai pu vérifier en
rencontrant des gens passant des coups
de fil donc là il ya vraiment une
défaillance à l'invitation de la défiant
administrative et une arrogance d'un
état central qui considèrent qu'il
s'occupe de tout et que les autres ne
seront pas ne seront pas capables de le
faire et le problème est là ça rejoint
ce que vous disiez sur le vaccin
l'espérance qui doit accompagner ça
c'est que et c'est le danger pour castex
véran macron c'est qu'on a l'impression
que la politique se résume à fermer ou
ouvrir selon des indicateurs sanitaires
donc c'est bon exercice
extraordinairement compliqué finalement
c'est à dire que plutôt qu accompagner
une vaccination de façon spectaculaire
dynamique pour donner envie aux gens
avec une vraie narration d'y aller en se
disant dans trois mois c'est fini on
ouvre on nous refait la soupe à la
grimace pour nous dire ça va être très
dur et puis on va refermer et puis on va
refermer puis le vaccin c'est pas tout
de suite parce qu'on est enfin
donc ces sept-là moi je pense que c'est
vraiment l'erreur pour n'avoir yal
erreurs logistiques cette histoire de
vaccins mais c'est une erreur de
communication on avait peut-être parler
avant noël qui moi m'a frappé dès le
premier vaccin de la dame anglaise et
ensuite ce monsieur william shakespeare
ou boris johnson a réussi à mettre en
scène cet événement de telle sorte qu'il
est devenu une aventure collective et
nationale et nous on a eu le vaccin
honteux au fait c'est là qu'on y verront
une vaccin ce qui est compliqué c'est
par ailleurs qu'on est face à une grande
ambiguïté des citoyens eux-mêmes
français eux mêmes c'est par lui mais il
aurait fallu s'appuyer sur eux
je pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet sur le
fait qu'il ya la défiance est donc le
gouvernement n'aime pas assez joué
l'exemplarité je suis très sensible à
l'idée qu'ils auraient 12 du tout se
faire vacciner vous pensez voilà vous
pensez que jean castex devraient se
faire vacciner public à bages pour
spéciaux bien sûr je pense que pas
seulement jean castex que je pense que
tout le gouvernement de l'allemagne
puisqu'il était malade mais je pense
qu'en tout cas il ya un élément
d'exemplarité sur lequel boris johnson a
très bien joué
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que on
voit bien effectivement on en a parlé
plusieurs fois des hommes dans ce
plateau que ce préfet qui ne fonctionne
pas avec les maires ça c'est une culture
et l'histoire de la france m donc il
faut faire évoluer très rapidement cette
histoire moi je crois que ça va se
passer parce que quelque part
justement la presse et la communication
des mères est bien meilleur pour dire on
est prêt à faire et que le gouvernement
va être obligé non pour hâter le pas
mais je trouve aussi que les critiques
adressées au gouvernement notamment par
son opposition institutionnelle sont
extraordinairement durs parce que je moi
je fais le pari que ça va fonctionner de
mieux en mieux oui mais souvent elles
sont mécaniques mais l'a par exemple
quand jean castex parle d'une polémique
stérile sur les vaccins dont 1
il s'en prend à son propre chef puisque
le premier avoir crié c'est emmanuel
macron et 2 s'il n'y avait pas eu une
polémique féconde toi qui l'avais pas eu
polémique ici ils seraient restés sur
leur rythme et il n'aurait pas accéléré
ils ont quand même accéléré parce qu'ils
se sont sentis contraints par la
pression de l'opinion et ils ont eu
raison
oui parce qu'on sentait monter quand
même un vent de colère et d'indignation
dans le pays
préoccupant donc oui mais voilà
l'ambiguïté ou en tout cas la
contradiction c'était à la fois on
voulait se faire vacciner et on voulait
pas se faire vacciner donc on est aussi
dans cette société où le fait de dire
moi je voudrais me faire vacciner mais
je me méfie du vin
st il ya une ambivalence oui je suis
d'accord et moi j'ai même vu des gens
sceptiques sur le vaccin est reproché à
macro de ne pas vacciner assez vite mais
ce que ça veut pas dire que l'art
politique consistait à s'appuyer sur les
gens favorables et à faire en sorte que
cette cette dynamique crée un mimétisme
positif est que les gens se disent on va
le faire
le fait qu'il fallait faire
l'exemplarité gouvernementales et
notamment ce que suggère en tous les cas
cet internaute qui nous dit ici on dit
confiné et sondé confiné tout ceux et
celles qui sont vaccinées une autre
question peut-être juste rapide réponse
le variant britannique ne serait-il pas
un effet du confinement le virer le
virus s'adapte et mute
je ne peux pas oui on est pas on n'est
pas scientifique et on répond donc à
nicole qui qui en a marre de voir trop
de médecins sur les plateaux afin qu'il
peut avoir des réponses sur
scientifiques la question en tous les
cas c'est juste rapidement mais est ce
que il ya un effet couvre-feu est ce
qu'il ya un effet on n'a pas encore des
sur le sur le premier confinement mais
parce que ces mesures de restriction ont
quand même une efficacité
ah ben c'est clair que ça une efficacité
sur le la dynamique de contamination
mais là avec ce variant britannique qui
est beaucoup plus contaminant c'est un
élément supplémentaire dont il faut
parler sur le fait de vacciner très vite
c'est à dire que évidemment les
contaminations vont reprendre parce que
le variant britannique il est sur le
territoire c'est un virus et ça va
évidemment se répandre et donc ce qui va
se passer c'est que il faut battre cette
dynamique de contamination en vaccinant
beaucoup plus vite
donc moi je prends juste ça comme un
élément supplémentaire et j'imagine que
beaucoup de médecins l'ont dit à jean
castex olivier ferrand sur le fait qu'il
faut accélérer les choses sur la
vaccination est peut-être prendre les
gens qui sont volontaires pour se faire
vacciner et pas seulement dire on a des
catégories on s'y tient stricto sensu et
moi je pense qu'il faudrait ajouter à
cela une
grande que campagne de dépistage
sérologique
c'est à dire que maintenant on doit être
à 15 % de français qui ont été atteints
du coc vide
si jamais on a appris la une revue
scientifique dit que l'immunité dure au
moins huit mois après si jamais on
savait qu'ils étaient ces gens d'abord
je pourrais vivre de façon plus sereine
et ne seraient pas obligées de se faire
vacciner en tout cas immédiatement et ça
permettrait déjà d'avancer de façon
spectaculaire et c'est un peu curieux
que que cette initiative ne soit reprise
l imagine qu'elle est compliqué à monter
mais en tout cas on pourrait au moins
inciter les gens à aller faire ce test
sérologique à cet intérêt ce qui peut
être fait et encore certains ont
pratiqué avec plus ou moins de succès
depuis le phare de ré cas ce que j'ai vu
autour de moi n'avaient pas les
immunités depuis en tout cas on a le
coeur net depuis le début beaucoup
demandent que les sciences que les
scientifiques travaillent sur un
traitement mais non ils préfèrent un
vaccin protège nicole sur fear alive et
bien nicole je vous propose qu'un jour
on est également ce débat fallait qu'il
plutôt privilégié des traitements que la
recherche des vaccins ce sera un autre
débat en tous les cas vous allez pouvoir
suivre en direct jean castex à partir de
18 heures sur le site du figaro ou bien
sur youtube merci beaucoup de nous avoir
suivi on posait la question quand même
juste on vous donne la réponse sur
twitter souhaitez vous que jean castex
annonce 1re confinement du pays
c'est pas visiblement ce qui ce qui
s'annonce mais vous êtes une légère
majorité à répondre non mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans le milieu
dans le courant de l'après midi
c est l inverse c'était plutôt d'une
majorité de gens qui étaient favorables
à un confinement merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis d'avoir répandu et à très
vite sur fear alive
[Musique]